[Applauso]
durante la pandemia si è fermato tutto
ci siamo sentiti spaventati arrabbiati
confusi non sapevamo cosa sarebbe
accaduto
ciò che c'è subito stato chiaro e che
saremo rimasti chiusi molto a lungo
nelle nostre case e malgrado la più
grande grandissima preoccupazione il mio
primo pensiero è stato questo se non lo
faccio adesso che ho tutto questo tempo
non lo farò mai più da tanti anni avevo
un sogno scrivere un libro sulla mia
pittrice preferita
è stata una ritrattista una pittrice
molto molto famosa Soprattutto negli
anni Venti e trenta del Novecento a
Parigi anche se si è rinnovata lungo
tutta la sua vita
dipingeva donne molto eleganti sensuali
ricche raffinate e i suoi nudi erano
molto provocanti scandalosi ma mai
volgari e la sua vita era è stata molto
lunga e molto molto movimentata avevano
uno stile unico non copiò mai da nessuno
non aderire movimenti a gruppi
e per lungo tempo mi sono chiesta come
mai nessuno avesse mai ehm deciso di
scrivere un romanzo su questa vita così
particolare era una donna emancipata ehm
intraprendente Eh una donna libera
soprattutto per l'epoca in cui è vissuta
così non appena è stato sancito lo stato
di lockdown ho detto Ok ci provo lo
faccio io e quindi ho iniziato subito a
ordinare tutte le monografie i libri che
ancora non possedevo su di lei Mi era
venuta subito la paura che anche i
corrieri non avrebbero più consegnato i
nostri ordini e che saremo rimasti
completamente isolati quindi ho comprato
tutto tutto ciò che che dovevo prendere
e mi sono
catapultata subito nella ricerca storica
ho cominciato a studiare a fare scalette
collegamenti a guardarmi tutti quanti i
video d'epoca che si trovavano nel web e
dopo questo lungo lungo lavoro che è
stato diciamo la cosa più corposa il
lavoro più corposo per la scrittura di
questo libro Ho iniziato a chiedermi chi
avrebbe raccontato questa storia parlare
in terza persona mi sembrava un po'
impersonale e parlare con la voce di
Tamara delle impi però
era un po' è ancora un po' il mio mito e
lo trovavo un po' irrispettoso Quindi ho
deciso di dare voce a Rosaria che
incontra la pittrice quando Entrambi
hanno 16 anni a pietrogrado e le rimane
accanto per un lungo periodo delle loro
vite prima diventando la sua governante
poi la sua amica confidente infine
addirittura la sua musa ispiratrice e
Parigi Londra ehm New York
e Roma Firenze sono soltanto alcune
delle città che fanno da scenario alle
vicende narrate che sono tutte vicende
storiche realmente accadute e che si
intersecano proprio con i fatti più
importanti dell'epoca come la
rivoluzione russa ehm la crisi economica
americana la seconda guerra mondiale e
poi i morti di 60tini Insomma tramite
Rosalia riusciamo ad avere una ehm una
visione
tutto tondo di Tamara de lempitska ho
cercato appunto di dare uno sguardo
intimo sulla vita di questa pittrice
qualche qualche mese dopo sono riuscita
a pubblicare questo mio libro che si
chiama appunto la governante di Madame
de Lempicka e questo libro è stato
davvero importante per me perché mi ha
rimesso in connessione con il mondo
dell'arte che è stato un mondo a cui
sono stata molto vicina con i miei studi
prima liceo artistico poi con
l'Accademia di belle arti ma dal quale
mi ero un po' allontanata e soprattutto
mi ha messo in sintonia ancora di più
con il mezzo espressivo che adesso
prediligo che è quello della della
scrittura e sono stata talmente presa da
questa da questa storia che subito Ha
iniziato a guardarmi intorno per cercare
un'altra figura a cui dedicare un
prossimo lavoro un prossimo libro e ho
iniziato proprio dai miei libri di
storia dell'arte i miei vecchi libri
parola e mi sono trovata subito davanti
ad una amara verità e cioè che
il numero delle artiste donne presente
proprio nei libri di storia dove gli
studenti imparano la storia dell'arte è
nettamente inferiore a quello degli
uomini ma questo perché ci sono state
comunque delle artiste che hanno dato il
loro grandissimo contributo al mondo
dell'arte e sono riuscite anche a
crearsi proprio una professione nei
secoli Ma chi sono queste donne
e soprattutto nell'antichità erano donne
nate in ambienti artistico erano ma ehm
figlie o sorelle di pittori oppure
scultori o mercanti d'arte che appunto
bazzicavano già un ambiente che
consentiva loro di imparare ehm la
professione
altre altri artisti molto conosciute più
o meno conosciuta erano le suore Sì
perché nei monasteri le suore oltre a
dedicarsi alla preghiera imparavano
Comunque la pittura la miniatura A volte
anche l'architettura e grazie a queste
queste loro competenze riuscivano
addirittura a mantenere a
contribuire al mantenimento dei luoghi
in cui vivevano dei conventi
altre donne
pittrici soprattutto le troviamo nelle
corti europee
a seguito di aristocratiche di cui
divennero le ritrattiste più o meno
ufficiali molte erano dame di compagnia
che proprio entrando in grande sintonia
con queste con queste persone riuscivano
ad offrire una visione
del Ritratto molto molto intima
le donne artiste si occupavano di
paesaggistica di natura morta di
ritratto potevano occuparsi di questi
temi una cosa che a lungo non potevano
fare ehm fu quella di copiare il corpo
nudo in certe epoche fu proprio loro
vietato assolutamente vietato ehm
copiare un corpo nudo in un Accademia
potevano essere modelle potevano stare
nude in mezzo alla gente ma non copiare
un corpo nudo
la storica dell'arte Linda nachlin da
una risposta alla domanda che dà il
titolo al suo saggio più famoso che è
questo Perché non ci sono state grandi
artisti Ed è proprio questa la questione
non ci sono state grandi artisti Perché
le donne non hanno potuto frequentare i
corsi di pittura e scultura al pari dei
loro contemporanei pensate che le colde
boart che era la scuola più famosa a
Parigi che era appunto il centro
dell'Arte è stata al centro dell'arte
per secoli è stata vietata alle donne
fino al 1897 cioè quasi fino al 900
prima di allora le donne potevano
formarsi negli Atelier di pittori che
facevano passare la loro la loro
presenza
ai loro corsi oppure frequentavano
queste nuove accademie che erano sorte
dopo la prima la seconda metà
dell'Ottocento in città ed erano
accademie private un po' meno
tradizionalista rispetto alla scuola
ufficiale Ma attenzione perché in questi
accademie potevano avere accesso pagando
una retta pari al doppio di quella dei
contemporanei uomini perché perché
l'arte per le donne era un lusso i Lussi
sappiamo si pagano Comunque nonostante
tutto ciò ci sono state delle donne che
hanno
hanno dato un contributo importantissimo
al al mondo dell'arte Io da poco aperto
questo blog la cui sezione principale si
chiama storia di artista e straordinarie
ed è un mio piccolo contributo per
ricordare queste persone per far
conoscere queste persone ma io credo che
la cosa principale
il ciò che andrebbe fatto a questo punto
è rivedere i libri di storia dell'arte i
testi scolastici e non parlo dei testi
della scuola secondaria di secondo grado
dove la storia dell'arte è una materia
di contorno molto spesso ma parlo anche
dei testi universitari Bisognerebbe
rivedere questi questi testi per offrire
agli studenti ai giovani una formazione
che parli di uguaglianza Io credo che la
storia non si possa cambiare ma si possa
riscrivere ed è veramente ora di
cambiare rotta Grazie
Grazie